faut-il parler ce soir d'une affaire
copé 27 février 2014
le scandale est révélée par le magazine
le point une agence de communication est
accusé d'avoir surfacturé l'organisation
de meetings de l'ump lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012
dans quel but c'est le début d'une
affaire qui impliquera nicolas sarkozy
la fait revivre à lyon selon lepoint
digue mallyon a volontairement gonfler
la facture
un surcoût d'environ 20% pour les
meetings certains frais aurait même
atteint le double des tarifs
habituellement pratiqués
tentons d'y voir plus clair en 2012
bygmalion s'occupe de l'organisation des
meetings du candidat sarkozy
les frais de campagne sont limitées par
la loi à 22,5 millions d'euros oui mais
voilà les meetings s'accumulent les
dépenses aussi et le soleil est vite
dépassé 18 5 millions d'euros de frais
en plus révèle libération un surcoût
qu'il faut masquer ces frais seront à
leur payer par l'ump à bygmalion
explique le quotidien
grâce à un système de fausses factures
pour des prestations bidon
l'avocat de bygmalion nie en bloc les
facturations de big ben à lyon
correspond à de réels prestations ont
été effectués à l'époque il n'ya donc ni
fausse facturation
ni surfacturation mais quelques jours
plus tard coup de théâtre
l'ancien directeur adjoint de la
campagne de sarkozy avoue sur bfm tv la
larme à l'oeil des frais de meetings ont
bien été imputée à l'ump et non pas à
l'association pour le financement de la
campagne de sarkozy
le problème c'est que ces dépenses ont
plafonné et qu'au delà d'une certaine
somme et bien on ne peut plus les
intégrer dans le compte de campagne et
il ya eu un dérapage
au lendemain de cette révélation et face
à la pression de son parti jean françois
copé démissionne de la présidence de
l'ump jean françois copé démissionnera
au 15 juin avoir enfreint la loi de
quelque manière que ce soit l'ump
elle doit assumer ses responsabilités et
nicolas sarkozy dans tout ça toujours le
27 mai 2014
il contredit son ancien directeur
adjoint de campagne en ce qui concerne
ma campagne je le dis à tous ceux qui
m'ont soutenu il n'y a jamais le moindre
système de double facturation
mais en novembre le patron de bygmalion
avoue aussi un système de surfacturation
à la demande de l'ump après des mois
d'enquêté
trois dirigeants de bygmalion ainsi que
des cadres du parti sont mis en examen
puis c'est au tour de sarkozy d'être
entendu par les juges à paris
c'était en février 2016 lorsque nicolas
sarkozy sort du bureau du juge hier soir
après plus de dix heures d'audition il
vient d'être à nouveau mise en examen
dans le dossier bygmalion pour
financement illégal de campagne
électorale celle de 2012 nicolas sarkozy
était-il au courant de ces fausses
factures c'est la question à laquelle
devra répondre le tribunal correctionnel
de paris
[Musique]